[Musique]
il
on retrouve la gare aval de ce côté là
et la gare amont de ce côté là avec
batoul et par lé système d'engrenages et
tout çà
et là en fait on a vraiment le système
complet tel qu'on va leur remontée sur
site c'est un projet assez unique et
c'est vrai que c'est toujours
intéressant de deux d'essayer de
comprendre les systèmes qui avait été
créé à l'époque qui sont uniques en fait
c'est des choses qu'on refera jamais
sans doute donc qu'on a jamais fait
qu'il aura jamais une mission rarissime
effectivement pour ce groupe spécialisé
dans l'aménagement des espaces de
montagne partout dans le monde sécurité
loisirs mobilité sont les piliers de la
maison tous les produits et toutes les
expertises qu'on a dans l'entreprise le
mend et c'est une entreprise qui a 20
ans et qui est né à la base de la
sécurité du déclenchement avalanche
qu'on va voir dans nos produits toute la
petite équipe venue de blois sur seille
est impressionné par la taille et
l'expertisé de l'entreprise à laquelle
ils ont confié leur téléphérique mais
l'estimé réciproque car les ingénieurs
du groupe avoue avoir été surpris par
les techniques utilisées par
l'entreprise jurassienne qui a conçu le
portelais au 19e siècle pour tout dire
ils ont même été surpris par
l'ingéniosité
des personnes de l'époque et on s'est
parfois creuser un petit peu la tête
pour savoir des vieilles pièces en fait
qu'il n'avait pas tourné depuis des
années il a fallu se creuser un petit
peu à l'aise pour savoir comment est-ce
que ça fonctionnait au début on se dit
mais non mais c'est pas possible ça
fonctionne pas comme ça ça peut pas
marcher tout est en fait c'est juste
parce qu'on n'avait pas compris la
manière de fonctionner de la machinerie
de l'époque
non mais nous sommes en train de monter
une garden est vrai yable d'un télésiège
débrayable annoncé nygaard qui destine
aux états unis
notre ancêtre téléphérique nous a permis
d'avoir accès à une installation moderne
de construction d'un téléphérique
donc là on a des poulies qui ont été
rénovés
donc les flasques qui ont été sablée et
traitée au zinc et les quartiers dedans
quand ils ont été repris bon c'est pas
facile de tourner ça c'est du nord
debout mais c'est pas évident il servait
entre deux et quatre fois par jour ouais
à l'époque mon arrière grand père je
vais partie de la conception avec voilà
c'était les ingénieux l'époque parce
qu'il fallait le faire les calculs
d'angle de me2 fait cérémonie et du coup
ça vous fait plaisir de le voir comme ça
au fond de vie j'en avais l'entretien
depuis 68 par jusqu'à maintenant
tout au long de la visite chaque pièce
est inspecté mais la méfiance initiale
fait vite place au sentiment d'avoir
fait le bon choix le petit groupe d'élus
et de passionnés de bois sur seille n'a
plus qu'une hâte voir revenir les
éléments du portelais au village
quand on est tombé sur le fait c'était
le premier téléphérique deux ans le de
france où l'un des premiers c'est
difficile à démontrer ça nous a tout de
suite plu et le fait d'aller là bas est
de voir cette équipe hyper passionnés
qu'ils voulaient
absolument reconstruire ce truc là sans
moyens jusqu'au départ il y avait pas de
moyens on a dit banco il faut qu'on
trouve des solutions la technologie elle
vient un peu des alpes et elle est allée
là bas ils ont construit quelque chose
dans le jura et quelque part c'est un
peu normal que nous entreprises savoyard
finalement le rénove finalement simple
c'est un peu logique
[Musique]